can't pass gas through gas
yeah
all right
[Laughter]
i'm sorry
before i trigger a cascade the
flatulence jokes
nothing we can't pass gas
right gas clouds cannot
move through other gas clouds right
without consequence it's like two hot
marshmallows touching each other
they stick right they've done that two
hot marshmallows absolutely it's like
contact cement so so everything else
passes through each other the gas sticks
together and that energy uh feeds the
formation of new stars
[Music]
is star talk
cosmic queries edition neil degrasse
tyson your personal astrophysicist
with chuck knight chuck and baby my
co-host hey neil what's happening
yeah yeah and you're on your on your
resume now start saying chuck nice actor
yes i mean in addition to comedian
what's up with that well i do i just
figured what the hell put it on my
resume
or do it
did you what say you were acting like a
comedian right that's what i'm i might
as well i'm acting like a comedian so uh
let me just put that on the resume put
that in there why not exactly
what i mean so
so today's topic um is a
fascinating one and it's so ubiquitous
it is it is
it is so ubiquitous that in fact in the
repertoire of public talks i give
one of them is entirely on this subject
okay
and so i will visit a town go to a
theater and 3 000 people will come and
listen to me talk for two hours on this
subject all right and it's called cosmic
collisions oh
oh have you been injured in an accident
[Laughter]
minus the attorney
yeah most cosmic collisions you're not
injured you are vaporized or you die in
some way wow yeah yeah so
things that go bump in the night and
then in the day
so much that drives this universe is the
result of things slamming into other
things that it's it's just astonishing
in ways you might not even thought about
it to give you a simple one okay for
example you've heard of aurora yeah you
know aurora borealis yeah
more than lights you know what the
southern lights are called
uh no
aurora australis oh okay that didn't
know that there you go
crikey yeah it's
it's your
it's your northern hemisphere
bias for you to only think of northern
lights this is true and not think of
southern lights right so
these are collisions
between
charged particles from the sun okay
in what we call the solar wind yeah and
our atmosphere our upper atmosphere
these particles slam into
atmospheric molecules
and it kicks them up to higher energy
levels
and
generally atoms and molecules don't like
staying at higher energy level if they
can help it right and so then they then
they de-excite
and to de-excite in many cases they get
married
in the cases
my life is way too exciting
i need to calm this down
so
they
so
they'll de-excite and in many of the
cases the de-excitation gives off
visible light and
it's the visible light is oxygen it's
nitrogen it's uh sometimes it's sodium
other sort of chemical elements in our
atmosphere that's what gives you the
different colors yeah like fireworks
like and and because the
the
uh
the solar wind comes in sort of blowing
in if i call it that it blows in from
across the solar system
so you so the the the
the the aurora can change shape like
instantly right it's it's an active
dynamic phenomenon and so that's just
one example of cosmic collisions wow and
so i'm leading off with that i don't
know if anyone's going to ask that but
apparently you got like a whole boatload
of questions on this very subject so
let's see what you've got you're
absolutely right it is a boat
look at this every time i do this and i
still have you see you're scrolling on
the screen like yeah yeah look at that
look at that look at that okay look at
that
it's it's unbelievable the the number of
questions we have here and because i
give an entire talk on this i am the
local expertise on the topic that's so
that's very very cool normally if it's a
new topic we bring in somebody who
helped us out on the keyboard not coming
from this one oh no i'm good for this
yeah cool very cool and if i don't know
i'll say i don't know
all right and you never believe me i was
gonna say okay i mean that's just not
gonna happen
all right actually that's not true there
are times when you're like okay well we
don't know
but that's not gonna stop you from
talking to the subject in some way
that's true because
we might know something plus there are
two kinds of i don't knows right there's
i neil degrasse tyson don't know because
i haven't learned it and we don't know
as it is unknown to all humans on earth
and part of what it is when you get your
phd in a subject is you learn thoroughly
what we know and what we don't know so
you know where the frontier is so you
can go there and advance human
understanding of the universe or
whatever is the subject of your
expertise but irrespective of the
question
the answer will never be from either you
nor any of your colleagues who hold that
phd
the answer will never be
[Music]
no as an educator i want you to leave
still having learned something right all
right but all right look we can test it
yeah i'm more literate than that yeah
okay by the way how cool would that be
or you know what else would be cool
when
when
you give an answer and at the end of it
you go dory
i know
all right here we go
this is dave bloomfield and he says
do we know where they're from i like
when they tell us where they're from no
date does not okay we gotta solicit that
next time okay so going so dave says hey
dr uh tyson lord nice i'm dave from
milwaukee sorry there it is neil he's
got it he put it inside the body of the
question
how likely is it that if that just means
you didn't read the questions in
i think i got advance to read these
questions
you know how long some of these
questions are
okay
dave who's secretly two sentences later
is from milwaukee there you go okay dade
as in david okay um that's so funny
because i'm so busted um
he says how likely is it that if an
asteroid were to hit the earth um that
we would actually notice it in time
enough to react
if we noticed it today how long do you
think it would take us to come up with
an executable plan
and yeah so i assume it assuming means
that if we know that tomorrow an
asteroid is going to hit
what can we do in the next 24 hours
right okay so of course it depends on
the size of the asteroid right uh so 65
million years ago when an asteroid the
size of mount everest struck the yucatan
peninsula what is today the yucatan
peninsula
left a you know 100 mile diameter crater
so on that order the size um it doesn't
you just kiss your ass goodbye you know
70 of the world's species
went extinct okay including all the big
tooth dinosaurs so there's certain size
asteroids where you just just sit on the
beach and just watch it happen
and
because there's really nothing we know
how to do about it right so that's just
that so it's not that in principle
nothing can be done right now
we have people fighting over whether
earth is flat or whether they should
take a vaccine and you think we're going
to coordinate in order to deflect an
asteroid i don't have that much
confidence in civilization sadly so but
if it's smaller
let's say something that might take out
a city oh okay that's yeah it's so
manageable death matter totally
manageable yeah so so what you do is you
find out where it's gonna hit usually
there's uncertainty
in the calculations of where it's going
to hit so we have what's called an error
circle
but if it's something coming in at an
angle it becomes an error ellipse an
uncertainty ellipse
so usually in other words you know
better where it's going to land left to
right than you will front to back
because it's headed in that direction
right right so
so the the the error ellipse is this
elongated circle
in the direction of the of the path of
the asteroid itself so you find out what
that is
and then evacuate it okay that's not all
that hard i mean think about what
happens i live in manhattan
and think about it every
24-hour period period
millions of people enter and exit that
island very poorly
in their work day okay through a system
of bridges and tunnels and boats even so
that's new york millions move okay so
uh it seems to me if we have some idea
of the region where we'll hit we could
notify local authorities and they can
clear out that zone allowing the thing
to fall so no one will actually get hit
right now if you happen to be nearby
it's going to make it it's going to
explode on impact
make a crater but that explosion will
scatter debris into the area and it'll
rain down
asteroid particles and earth particles
that have been kicked up so but that's
less deadly than being where it actually
hits and explodes and by the way it will
explode
and you say well how is it going to
explode if it doesn't have any any bombs
so here's how that works okay the very
subtle point uh it's a high speed impact
which has a very specific meaning
it's not just that it's going fast all
right okay so here's an object moving
through space and you ask well how fast
is it going how fast is it going so you
get its speed it'll hit us at a minimum
of 25 000 miles an hour
okay that's about seven miles per second
as a minimum
all right but that's if it just sort of
fell to earth if it has motion of its
own
combined with motion from earth
then what you really care about is the
closing speed and then that could be up
upwards of 40 000 miles an hour okay uh
nearly double that okay so you have to
just sort of watch for those numbers so
so here we go so here's a coming in at
very high speeds now you can calculate
what we call the kinetic energy you
probably heard the term
it's a very specific measurement you
make yes how much mass is there
and how fast is it going mm-hmm okay
that's all the only two
things you need you need that's all you
need and so the connecticut cake is
one-half times the mass of the object
times its velocity squared
okay
but the mass times the velocity squared
oh by the way it's not an accident
that the famous
what's einstein's most famous equation e
equals m c squared notice there's a mass
right and c is the speed of light
squared right but notice it's a mass and
a velocity squared that's it it's an
energy so mass and a velocity squares
are energy
no matter how you slice them so look one
way to write down a value of energy is
the mass times the the velocity of that
object squared that's all that's what
i'm talking about it's not an accident
that equals mc squared has that same
structure to it so kinetic energy is one
half mv squared all right
write down that number
okay write it down right now ask
yourself what's holding the thing
together
right all right
so look at you go down to the molecules
and they're molecules connected to each
other
inside this solid object and you can ask
with what energy are these molecules
hanging on to each other
okay so imagine you're not standing next
to that we just lock elbows okay so all
just molecules locking elbows what will
it take for two people to pull us apart
that's a certain energy
all right double edger will either
release your grip
or rip your arm off or rip your arm off
right both of them you can calculate
what those you can either release the
molecule or bust the molecule open all
right right do that for all
molecules in the object
that's a total ener it's called a
binding energy of the object okay so now
i have a kinetic energy of its motion
and a binding energy of the physical
object and you ask yourself which of
these is larger
if the kinetic energy is larger
than the binding energy
we'll call it a high-speed collision
and here's what happens this object is
coming in and slams into earth
with very high kinetic energy
well velocity is one of the terms in the
kinetic energy equation after it hits
earth how fast is it moving
well
oh minus whatever
it how fast it oh as it hits earth
velocity oh it already hit earth it hit
earth how fast is it moving it's
it's just stopped
give me a velocity
right yeah
oh minus the no no
i just asked a simple question oh how
fast is it moving the velocity what is
the velocity after it has hit the earth
oh i don't know yes you do it hit earth
oh zero thank you
zero it's zero
okay so then i asked you
where did all the kinetic energy go
you know such thing as a free lunch in
this universe so
all that kinetic energy
on impact with the earth it did it
several things one it makes a crater
it's it's flies things up into space but
it also goes back into the object itself
completely destabilizing
everything that's binding it together
because it's more energy that's holding
it together
and so the instant that happens the
thing can't stay together and so it
explodes
period
that's how you get the explosion that's
why you get it the explosion
in fact that's why every crater you have
ever seen on the moon is a good example
but look anywhere in the solar system is
a perfect circle
even if these suckers come in at an
angle you think oh it'll make an oval
crate yes the uncertainty ellipse is an
ellipse but once it hits
it explodes and the explosion is what we
say is isotropic it's it's the force is
the same in every direction it makes a
perfectly circular crater and
usually this the object can't be found
it'll vaporize 90 something percent of
the object if you're going to look for a
big rock that's there you're not going
to find it
wow in fact they did you know that big
as arizona is known for its holes in the
ground okay yeah so one of them is a
meteor crater we call it oh you mean
actual celestial
caused holes in it
i thought you meant dive bars i was
going to say yeah yeah
you're absolutely right that's it
those are holes in the wall not falling
on the ground oh that's right they are
yeah yeah that's right so
uh so with that
uh when people said you know if this is
a if this is left by a meteor there
ought to be a big meteor down in the
middle so they started excavating they
couldn't find anything
it's before we understood this whole
concept of a high speed impact and a
high velocity impact where you basically
vaporize the object in an explosion it's
a cosmic pillow fight where the pillow
explodes and there's all the feathers
are all
and we're still frolicking well that's
it that's an important analogy because
a high speed collision has
not as much to do with the speed as it
does what is the thing made of right so
what's holding your pillow together is
some stitching around the edge exactly
if i slam it hard with more energy than
that stitching
and it hits you upside the head the
stitching will break
and the pillow will break open because
in that moment the pillow engaged in a
high speed collision yeah same thing
happens with a sock full of oranges
don't ask me how i know
yeah i'm not coming over your next
sleepover
all right so yeah that's a long answer
to that very that very good question nah
that was cool man just evacuate you can
do it you can evacuate in 24 hours
that's why we have roads right and why
everybody has cars so plus you can
evacuate in every direction
okay in most places unless you're like
in the florida keys or something now you
got to go just that one direction by the
way if it falls in the ocean then you
got to watch out for the tsunami
okay
yeah just something to keep in mind but
most of the earth is ocean right and yes
and to just leave the away from the
coastline and most of that which is land
is not inhabited so chances are
it's not going to hit a city even if it
had the power to destroy one
well that's no i can sleep okay yeah
yeah there you go that's not bad
give me another one
okay this is theresa annosky she says
how can there be a collision cosmic or
otherwise without a lawyer
so this is a being
dimension for lawyer ads right right
exactly
are you is your house destroyed by a
meter
yeah who are you going to sue on that
right yeah yeah yeah so just an
interesting point there the
uh one of the
brightest most devastating recent
recent now nine years ago was in
chelyabinx russia there was an air blast
of an asteroid 17 meters across
some of the best footage we have of that
coming in are from forward facing
dash
footage of cars
and
so here's an interesting point
and that's
you know europe and uh and parts of asia
have these
to obtain video
of a collision that you might be in
which reduces the need for lawyers
okay often a lawyer is arguing whether
something did or didn't happen or who
was at fault or who was more at fault
than they're claiming and all this if
you have video that just cuts through so
much
of what might otherwise happen in a
courtroom
so you can imagine a day where
everything i mean i wouldn't want this
because it's an invasion of privacy but
if everything we've made a video of
everything
well okay that didn't make a difference
with uh
in los angeles in 1991 did not i was
about to say what
did i say
sorry
you have a lot of video you want
what's that boy's name i forgot
that was rodney king rodney okay so i
take it back apparently video doesn't
matter in some cases
okay if you're getting your ass whooped
by the cops apparently it doesn't matter
but for everything else right exactly
so yeah
it's a testament to the fact that human
sensory systems
are rife with error
not only
seeing what isn't there thinking you're
not seeing something that is hearing
something that's not perceiving so it's
such rife with error that science really
didn't take off
until we were able to replace our senses
with machines that would have a
reliability that we could only dream of
having with our own eyes ears nose mouth
and touch chuck we got to take a quick
break but when we come back more cosmic
queries
on cosmic collisions on star talk
we're back star talk cosmic queries
cosmic collisions is the subject one of
my favorite subjects in fact i give a
series of public talks around the
country uh at a theater near you uh and
i give the host a choice of what topics
they might want to hear
from me because i have nothing really to
sell you other than the universe itself
and the ticket
and and so they so they they see the the
i don't have a product to tell you other
than like i said university i don't know
what you meant and so it's
one of the subject is cosmic collisions
and every now and then they pick that
and they're usually in for a treat
because it's it's just a fun topic and
so many things shape the universe by
slamming into other things giving us
what we think of as something that's
beautiful or or or spectacular
they're really just some coming upside
the head of something else and i think
we also have a odd fascination with the
macabre and uh yes we do we do yeah
people just want to know like how are we
gonna die right how's it all in like
right it's like the same thing you watch
nascar for for the crash oh yeah yeah
not one crash this was the worst race
ever
all right here we go this is deb beach
deb says hey dr tyson a recent article
from the new york times about research
in 2003 astrophysics working with
astrophysicists working with nasa's
orbiting chandra x-ray observatory the
article notes that the sound waves were
coming from a giant cluster of galaxies
in the constellation perseus caused by
explosions from a huge black hole 250
million light years away they provided a
sound clip that was modified so that we
could hear the quote unquote
music of the black hole my question is
how musical noisy is our galaxy of and
what other phenomena creates
sounds
in
space
uh here's the thing
here's the thing
i'm
i'm not a fan of turning astrophysical
data into sound
i i get it and it has some value i'm
just not a fan because of all of the
off-ramps that that
gives a person into thinking the wrong
thing about the universe okay so okay so
let me just start it out by saying
anything any energy
that
creates a change of pressure
through a medium
is creating sound that's how your
eardrum works that's how your eardrum
works okay there's air is is it's
pressure in the air it puts pressure on
the eardrum it gets converted to
electrical chemical signals that your
brain then interprets as sound okay
anything so so most things
actually make sounds okay if you could
if you could pull the microphone up to
the sun it is gurgling and they're like
pressure waves inside the sun
oh my gosh
the sun is actually boiling all right
it's a very hot it's hot in the middle
less hot at the surface and anytime you
have a heat
gradient if that gradient is strong
enough it will gradient is a fast change
in what it is then you'll have boiling
such as what would happen on your stove
so
point is
um what they did was they found places
in the universe
where
the medium the interstellar
intergalactic medium depending on which
research results they're looking at that
they're these pressure waves through it
now but they're very low frequency
very
low
[Laughter]
just google some youtube videos of it it
is an it is a it is a hoot it's nutty
man it's nutty they go the voice is so
low you can almost look at their their
their vocal cords vibrate you know right
yeah
anyhow so it is such low frequency that
in order to hear it they had to
artificially boost the frequency
by
47 48 octaves well that's
nothing like
like what you heard then right so if you
were there you just wouldn't hear it the
sound would sort of wash over you you
wouldn't even know it was sound right so
you you boost the frequency now you can
hear it in this narrow range well we
have several orders of magnitude 20
hertz to 20 000 hertz if i remember
correctly and that's a nice range but
it's small compared to the total
possible ranges that are out there go
ask your dog okay yeah
okay
all right so
that's you know it's funny chuck you and
i grew up at a time when
in the our biology books the human body
was praised at some kind of pinnacle of
evolution yeah we still use our dog to
sniff out drugs because we can't right
where dogs can hear frequencies we can't
yeah people say if a tree fell in a
forest and no one was there to hear it
did it make sound yeah because the dogs
heard it right that's what your dog is
here and every time you see him just
look up like what
and there's nothing going on just you
know there's nothing
they heard the tree for i don't know he
was like another tree a truck i'm gonna
i'm gonna tweet that right he was like
wait somebody just destroyed my bathroom
i never eat on that tree yesterday
another perfectly good bathroom just
destroyed
[Laughter]
so
uh so anyhow the
point is that if you do that and then
say these are the sounds of the universe
it's a little misleading because it's
not what you would hear
plus most of the rest of this of space
is empty
and sound needs a medium through which
to transmit
and so not only wouldn't you hear it
when it was there it wouldn't travel to
you anyway
so that's why i'm always a little
uncomfortable
talking about and thinking about
sounds in space that's it and uh and by
the way
there's a medical condition called
synesthesia
i find a fascinating condition where you
your sensory wiring is crossed
so i think i get it right there's some
people who hear colors
who see sounds
okay
yeah so it's fascinating sort of
cross-wiring of your senses so what
we've also done
is we've taken frequencies of light
in images
and because the different frequencies
there's you know red orange yellow green
blue violet those are different
frequencies of light but we see way more
than that with our modern equipment we
see ultraviolet infrared x-rays gamma
rays so i've seen some people take those
frequencies and attach a sound to them
and then
they have that sound emanating from an
image and the combination of sounds from
all the data that's in the picture
so when i first heard that i said no
that's that's wrong you can't do that
but then i realized i was i was speaking
with richard dawkins who strongly
suspects
that because bats are mammals
and they have basically the same brains
we do a lot of the same processing power
he thinks that
bats
hear
in color
because what else would they be doing
with the part of their brain that sees
color why not hand it the audio signals
that they're getting from their
echolocation
so
if a bat
can hear
color
then i thought to myself why should i
have a problem with us
seeing
sounds
right
see so
so in that regard
maybe we're at the beginning of a whole
new way
to bring data to people because if
you're sight impaired for example
you want to hear what the picture looks
like i mean why not that's kind of
yeah it'd be kind of cool there's surely
a whole future in that if if you're if
you're hearing impaired or vision
impaired you bring the data into another
sense
but you want to do it sort of
authentically right if there's a
separation of frequencies you map them
into a new set of frequencies that are
still separated in that new regime so
anyhow so yeah so that's how you get
sounds in the universe
and
by the way collisions and things they
all make sounds if you're right where
they are but you wouldn't hear them if
you're out in space that's the only
difference would so in that regard star
wars would be silent movie right
just so you know and uh and there goes
the box office
god it was
it was so great if if only they had some
kind of sound effects with it it would
have been even so much better
yeah we don't like watching silent
explosions i think that's what that
comes down to that's america baby
we're really good at blowing stuff up
and we're less good at knowing where the
pieces go at the end by the way that's a
whole other conversation chuck we gotta
take a quick break when we come back
part three of our three segment cosmic
queries
about cosmic collisions
chuck we're back you know i've been
giving sort of luxurious answers to
those several questions we've had so far
that's not awesome question no let's do
a little bit of lightning round
i want to show people i'm capable of
that okay yeah i just say we do another
show a second show
if you didn't get your question answered
asked and come back we'll do it again
all right do it again you'll get your
question i'll you know i'm still gonna
try it okay okay we'll try here we go
here we go zachary
clyre clear clear
clear okay zachary says greetings dr
tyson lord nice i recently read that
upon a recent published work in which
researchers suggest that when two
progenitor galaxies collided head-on
their dark matter and stars would have
sailed past each other the dark matter
would not have interacted with the stars
which would not have been able to
uh
too far apart to collide but as the dark
matter and the stars sped up
the gas in the space between the two
galaxies and stars would have crashed
together compacted and slowed down
leaving a trail of matter that formed
dun dun dun
a new galaxy you just described
galaxy sex bro
[Laughter]
did this question have that the sound
effects in there too or did you add
those no
everything everything
spoken there is accurate so here's what
happens the galaxy collision is one of
the most beautiful balletic
things you've ever seen
so first of all galaxies are mostly
empty of stars right all right so if
there were just a few bumblebees
flying randomly
in the continental united states there's
a greater chance that two of them would
accidentally bump into each other
than for two stars to collide
when when two galaxies um come together
in space that's how empty empty space is
okay wow
so when the two galaxies come they will
basically pass through each other and
come out the other side okay the dark
matter whatever that is we don't know
what it is the dark matter will do the
same why because dark matter not only
doesn't interact
physically with our matter it doesn't
interact
chemically
it doesn't interact with itself
so it would have to interact in order to
make a dark matter
planet for example or dark matter star
something has to work such that
it can become compactified why are you a
solid object chuck because your
molecules are sticky sticking to each
other in some way that turn you into
chuck
dark matter as far as we know has no
ability to stick to us or to stick to
itself so the dark matter passes through
but the gas clouds
oh they're not gonna you can't pass gas
through gas
yeah
all right
[Laughter]
i'm sorry
before i trigger a cascade
the flatulence jokes from objects
nothing we can't pass gas
right
gas clouds cannot
move through other gas clouds right
without consequence it's like two hot
marshmallows touching each other
they stick right you you've done that
too hot marshmallows absolutely it's
like it's like contact cement so so
everything else passes through each
other the gas sticks together and that
energy
uh feeds the formation of new stars
and so you could so these for these
these these
filaments of gas
that are left over from these collisions
we can basically form an entire family
of dwarf galaxies by doing this
that
is pretty damn amazing so yeah so these
are collisions and
uh the problem is it takes about a
quarter billion years to fully go
through this collision so we know they
happened primarily only because we
simulate them on the computers
and just just
i want you to appreciate my people okay
if you're gonna collide two galaxies
every
inch
the galaxy moves closer to itself
the sum of all the gravity vectors
operating on every point in space
changes
right so if you're a star
you take three steps to the left
everybody else took three steps to
whatever they're going and now the total
gravity field is different so you have
to recalculate what's tugging on you and
in what direction
and once you go through this exercise
that's when you find this this
extraordinarily balletic collision it's
like two it's like a train wreck right
the the structure the beautiful
structures of the galaxies get
completely destroyed and distorted and
it's just beautiful so if i wanted to
see a phenomenon in the universe i would
want front row seats for a quarter
billion years on the collision of
galaxies
very cool oh i left something out so the
these gas clouds will make their own
shards of galaxies but the system of
stars
they will pass through each other come
out the other side but they still see
one another and then they'll slow down
stop and then collide again
and this will continue until it settles
into a new galaxy
into a new galaxy that is completely
that has lost all of its if there were
spiral galaxies and completely lost all
of its beautiful spiral structure and
become one big giant blob of stars and
if they each had black holes the black
holes will find each other and merge in
the middle
okay yeah all right so back up when
that's happening yeah man
all right that was not a sound bite
answer so but keep going
that was that was fascinating
fascinating here we go uh uh hello dr
tyson lord nice uh this has been
plaguing me for a couple of years now
who is this who is it oh i'm sorry yeah
james weldon sorry james thank you yeah
yeah uh this has been plaguing me for a
couple of years now is it possible the
big bang and the big rip
are
causally
connected
i heard from a science youtuber once
that the amount of energy needed to
split elementary particles such as
quarks is so infinitely great that the
very act would mathematically create new
elementary particles rather than
actually splitting them well i'd like
that by the way the namesake of this
format cosmic queries became a book
published by national geographic a
couple of years ago and there's an
entire section on how the universe will
end
right and all the hypotheses are there
including the big rip
which would happen in 22 billion years
if in fact the acceleration of the
universe continues and then
so
here's what's interesting about the
universe wherever you have a lot of
energy
stuff happens
stuff happens i'll give you an example
okay do you know what protons and
neutrons are made out of
um sugar and spice and everything nice
yes precisely that junction
made out of quarks okay now we've never
found an isolated quark they're always
in pairs
okay always yeah okay all right so now
well why not why don't we just get in
there and rip them apart okay well
here's what happens as you pull them
apart they pull on each other more
strongly oh as the distance increases
it's like a finger puzzle okay
or or
something even do people have finger
puzzles anymore no okay they don't
really have but well we're just a rubber
band does that right that's true yeah
right as you pull on it it's pulling on
you strong more strongly so this is a
force that operates the way a rubber
band does but watch what happens
if you pull on a cork with enough
strength
i finally got it check check i got it i
got it and then it snaps into two
the energy you put in
was exactly enough
for the snapping rubber band to create
another cork
and now you have two pairs of quarks
instead of one
nice yes yes it is it is like don't
f with me yeah
you see i'm happy here as a peer court
yeah
that's some lone shark stuff right there
that's right
so i'd like the idea
that the energy required to rip the
universe the very fabric is sufficiently
high that it could create multiple big
bangs i haven't researched that enough
to know if there's something that would
prevent it but i'm telling you that
energy is opportunistic
right and so i like that possibility is
it kind of cool it's just so it could be
that our big bang was somebody else's
biggest somebody's big rip yeah yeah
there you go man i don't
i don't want everything to come from any
term anything termed the big rip
so
i don't want that to be
i don't
i don't know what to call it is the
universe is ripping i don't know what
else i'm gonna do you know yeah but if
you go if you check out the book uh
there's a whole section if you want to
know all the ways the world would end
all right chuck i don't do we spend so
much time check we don't have time oh no
all right one more quick quick quick
quick all right here we go
dr tyson lord nice when we detected
gravitation
wait wait who was it who was it jason
whiter okay okay jason whiter or okay uh
dr seissen lord knights when we detected
gravitational waves from the collision
of two black holes what happened to
their
event horizons oh
very whoa that's a great question it it
is it is and in fact don't we have an
explainer on this with our black hole in
residence uh black hole expert in
residence john 11.
yes i think we we do talk about this yes
we do i think it was in an explainer but
i'll just tell you right now and then we
got to call it a quits okay um so
what happens is the two event horizons
merge to become one larger or vent
horizon
surrounding the total mass of the two
objects together
that's what happens
uh okay they enter each other's event
horizon when this happens and janna
gives a brilliant explanation for how
that happens and why it happens and so i
recommend you do a fast search on that
and you'll get there
all right chuck we're going to call it
quits there that was great man and guess
what we still have
like 60 questions left
which is awesome all right we'll do this
again we totally will do this again
cosmic queries second edition of the
sequel
we'll just number them up because
there's no end of this and like i said
it's one of my favorite subjects so
chuck tweeting at chuck nice comic thank
you sir yes i never give my social media
handles on this but maybe uh because you
don't need to
if i had 14 million people
following me on anything
and by the way i would stop giving it
like hey guys
stop take it easy chill out okay i need
a second can i get a second you know
all right i'll do this one time okay on
twitter it's neil tyson right and on
everything else it's neil degrasse tyson
on facebook tick tock even and the tick
tock is is an official tick tock of star
talk by the way
we have a bunch of us making sure that
works out and i'm i'm in all the content
but we have people experts tick tock you
know people one-third my age that's
that's the difference i like your text
experts that's cool man oh that's so
funny
yeah you got a toddler just like here's
your problem
you're not going to be able to get
engagement if you keep doing this
all right this has been cosmic queries
cosmic collisions edition the first of
what will surely be many
neil degrasse tyson here keep looking up
[Music]
you